It's a regular day at a grocery store
in the city of Davis. People are
picking up their favorite fruits and
vegetables. Many of these foods,
however, didn't used to look like the
way they do now. Years of selective
breeding have changed the way many
modern foods look. To see what I mean,
let's check out a Ted Talk by Dr.
Pamela Ronald in 2015.
Now, genetic modification is not new.
Virtually everything we eat has been
genetically modified in some manner.
On the left is an image of the ancient
ancestor of modern corn. Now take a
look at the ancient ancestor of banana,
and unappetizing brussel sprouts, and
eggplant, so beautiful.
Historically, plants like the ones Dr.
Ronald talked about have been
genetically altered by a practice
called selective breeding. This
involves choosing a distinguishable
trait in a fully grown plant to
actively select for. Take height, for
instance. In this example, the tallest
two trees are selected for breeding.
This creates offspring that are overall
taller than the previous generation.